big day today Dolly three the third
version of the legendary text to image
AI is coming no we can't try this yet
there is no product or paper yet only
the initial announcement now it seems
that it does three things better than
all the other techniques out there so
what does it do well well first it
listens now I hear you asking doctor
what do you mean by that well with other
techniques important parts of our prompt
often get lost however not here when we
enter a detailed prompt it really tries
to take all of it into consideration if
I write the prompt I want to get that
mustache to be noteworthy and this one I
would say is and some of these plants
can get bloody long and I just kept
looking and looking but I think I might
see everything that was requested here
even for things that are really
difficult to paint or sometimes even
imagine try to imagine a whirlwind of
porcelain fragments harmonious fluid
forms in a dream-like atmosphere and so
on
excellent two I am wondering can this
really compete I mean me journey and
stable diffusion have become so
incredibly good I can imagine that even
Dolly 3 might have a hard time competing
now we have a little indication here oh
yes the legendary prompt from Dolly too
an expressive oil painting of a
basketball player dunking depicted as an
explosion of a nebula and now look this
is what it looks like with version 3.
more detail more definition more life I
find it a great deal better great job
little Ai and three now hold on to your
papers fellow Scholars for better
integration with chat GPT you see we
don't even need to write the prompts
directly we can even ask it to make up a
new character let's call him Larry the
Hedgehog and we get lay Larry is amazing
so let's get some more images and now
you immediately see that getting several
images created about the same character
is not a trivial matter at all we've
looked at a bunch of papers that tried
to pull that off and now it is here but
every Hedgehog needs a house so it can
imagine that too that is a beautiful
house and look at that text fantastic I
really want that because we have been
promised proper tech support in text to
image and at least for me it never quite
worked out without significant cherry
picking I hope this is gonna be better
here and then finally we can ask for
stickers of the amazing Larry and even a
bedtime story with him I have a
seven-year-old daughter and just
thinking about the amount of fun we are
going to have with this gives me
goosebumps love it thank you so much now
one more thing there is no paper
here I can only comment on what I see in
the announcement and the cases that we
see here are usually not the average but
the best case scenarios however we will
be able to try this and find out soon no
doubt what a time to be alive I was also
happy to see that it will not create an
image in the style of a living artist
and when I watch their video what do I
see proper and I mean proper scholarly
representation that is what I see well
done fellow Scholars if you are looking
for inexpensive Cloud gpus for AI Lambda
now offers the best prices in the world
for GPU Cloud compute no commitment or
negotiation required just sign up and
launch an instance and hold on to your
papers because with the Lambda GPU cloud
you can now get on-demand h100 instances
for just 199 per hour yes 199 and they
are one of the first Cloud providers to
offer publicly available on-demand h100
XS did I mention they also offer
persistent storage so join researchers
at organizations like apple MIT and
Caltech in using Lambda Cloud instances
workstations or servers make sure to go
to lambdalabs.com papers to sign up for
one of their amazing GPU instances today